Отже Добрий день шановні колеги вітаємо
вас сьогодні на тижні
професійно-технічної освіти і сьогодні
ми проводимо день студентів а це означає
що нас найближчі півтори години очікує Я
сподіваюсь дуже приємно спілкування з
учнями закладів професійної освіти Мене
звати Ірина Шумик я очолюю директорат
професійної освіти в Міністерстві освіти
і науки і сьогодні буду вашим
модератором тут сьогодні зібралися
дорослі і молоді люди для того щоб
поспілкуватися про їхнє життя буття у
закладах професійної освіти про їхні
професії про їхнє життя просто деньське
учнівське самоврядування і про величезну
величезну місію про волонтерські роботи
яку дуже активно залучені Наші учні і Ми
сьогодні хочемо почути про ваші успіхи
Ми сьогодні хочемо поділитися досвідом
одне з одним і і я ще раз Всіх вітаю хто
доєднався до нас
безпосередньо в ефірі в студії а нас тут
ну надзвичайно багато майже 200
учасників і дуже Вітаю тих хто
доєднується до нас на нашій прямій
трансляції у Ютубі Я сподіваюся що всі
готові до спілкування і зараз передаю
слово але вас так багато тому не можу
сказати чи вже підключився чи не
підключився Зараз ми все перевіримо
нашому заступнику міністру профільного
заступнику міністра
освіти і науки який координує питання
професійної освіти дмитру завгородньому
Дмитро вам слово для привітання
Всіх вітаю
ну почну почну з того що дуже-дуже радий
всіх вас тут бачити такі усміхнені
молоді обличчя Я хотів би сказати що на
мою думку зараз більше ближче круто бути
молодою людиною навчатися в Україні саме
зараз чому
ми Всі впевнені що достатньо скоро ми
переможемо і почнеться наступний етап
життів України який вже прийнято
називати таким етапом відмовлення
Можливо ще чуєте такий термін почнеться
відновлення відбудова а будівництва і
так далі насправді чому це круто не лише
через те що буде багато вакансії в сфері
будівництва а і через те що
дуже-дуже сильно зміниться взагалі наша
країна
і ви можете трошки подумати Після цієї
зустрічі Уявляти собі якою буде Україна
майбутнього яке ви б хотіли мати своє
там місце всій Україні майбутнього як де
б ви хотіли реалізувати себе в цій
Україні майбутньому тому що на мою
особисту думку вона буде зовсім іншою і
в ній буде дуже багато відмінностей Я
хотів би трошки поділитися своїми
думками щодо того які саме ці
відмінності що вам було потім легше
пофантазувати ну Для прикладу Ми Точно
знаємо що у нас величезна міграція так
купа людей виїхали за кордон тому купа
людей будуть повертатися в Україну
отримавши певним міжнародний досвід але
крім цього це вплине і на розвиток
туризму тому що уявіть як багато в світі
є зараз людей які знають про Україну і
які ніколи тут не були і коли для них це
буде безпечно скільки людей захочуть
відвідати якесь місто в Україні яке
стало вже легендою в світових новинах і
так далі
або наприклад сфера енергетики яка дуже
суттєво постраждала
від
російської агресії і яка буде
трансформована скоріш за все в якусь
нову зелену енергетику як буде
розвиватися атомна енергетика і так далі
на скільки це війна взагалі вплинула на
наше сприйняття того якою має бути сфера
енерго або наприклад питання експорту
яке так само зав'язане на тому що ми
стали настільки відомою в світі країною
і скільки різних товарів не
масового якогось виробництва не лише там
нашої агроекспорту чи ще щось А
якесь маленького підприємництва може
працювати на експорту скільки про нас
знає весь
крім цього це все накладається на зміни
які ви бачите щодня в усьому світі це
технологічні зміни і сподіваюся що ви
вже потрошки починаєте використовувати
штучний інтелект для того щоб виконувати
домашні завдання для того щоб
писати твори реферати або дізнаватись
більше за допомогою там чай GPT або
генерувати зображення як він бджолів це
теж стане невід'ємною частиною вашого
майбутнього в першу чергу ваші роботи і
так далі тому я дуже сподіваюся що всі
ці речі всі ці зміни ви будете
враховувати якось або намагатися їх
враховувати для того щоб планувати якесь
своє подальше життя тому що я впевнений
що воно буде зовсім не таким яким Там ми
його собі уявляли декілька років тому до
чого ми йшли і що Ми планували Доброго
дня
у наше з Іриною
колегами завдання в першу чергу це
трансформація системи освіти
трансформація під осіб всі умови
невизначеності і це майбутнє яке Ми
намагаємося собі уявляти і
ті зміни які ми намагаємося впровадити
або будемо також впроваджувати вони
спрямовані саме на те щоб ви Ваші друзі
ваші колеги змогли краще знайти себе в
цьому світі майбутнього який ми
намагаємося фантазувати намагаємося його
собі уявити
І звісно для цього треба дуже багато
чого змінити оскільки Світ змінюється
набагато швидше ніж ті заклади в яких ви
навчаєтесь Я впевнений що якщо у когось
з вас батьки навчалися в тому самому
закладі то можливо Там не дуже сильно
відрізняється аудиторія а можливо навіть
той самий вчитель викладає який викладав
В мене в школі так було вчитель які мені
викладав викладали для моєї мами колись
і так далі і часто і підручник був той
самий але ми точно розуміємо що світ вже
не буде таким самим ми Нам треба щось
змінювати коли ми кажемо про такі
масштабні зміни і взагалі в таких теорії
на своєму це масштабних змін ви не
можете прийти на якусь там позицію як в
маленьке підприємство і сказати все
Завтра ми почнемо жити по-іншому і тут
будуть величезні зміни і завтрашнього
дня давайте викладати підприємництво
індастріл дизайн давайте викладати
англійською мовою і так далі це так не
працює так великі системи вони
змінюються поступово і змінюються дуже
складно і тому щоб змінювати великі
системи нам потрібно залучати назвемо це
англійською мовою це називається стиль
ходерів як як правильно сказати кого нам
треба залучати
старі на листи колдерів досить вживане
слово зараз в Україні але я ж хочу так
щоб всім зрозуміло треба всіх залучати
до цих процесів всіх ключових бактерів
які які в цих змінах нам можуть
допомогти і тому Ми дуже хочемо залучати
до цього вас тому що ви є якби
споживачем так в цій системі освіти в
першу чергу але ви є і великим рушієм
для змін тобто Якщо ви будете вимагати
цих змін Якщо ви будете розуміти яких
саме змін ви хочете Якщо ви будете
надавати нам зворотний зв'язок стосовно
того чи виходить у нас ще змінювати чи
ні і де ми робимо якісь помилки А де
робимо успіхи Мені здається ми будемо
рухатися набагато ефективніше і швидше
тому ми от відкриті до ваших пропозицій
побажань
обов'язково це побажання висловлювати
одразу зараз або навіть сьогодні але ну
спробуємо почути всі ваші думки а після
цього будемо
довго і наполегливо пробувати залучати
вас ваших друзів ваших колег залучати
студентів з усієї України для того щоб
вони теж впливали на ці зміни які там
дуже і дуже потрібні прямо зараз тому
дуже вам дякую Сподіваюся мене цікаву
цікаву ідею Дякую
Дмитро Дякую Шановні колеги власне Я
думаю що можливо ми вже почали розбивати
певні стереотипи про чиновників Тобто ви
можете побачити Дмитра і зрозуміти що
дійсно сьогодні
професійно-технічна освіта в гарних
добрих руках і яка має креативного
керівника І дійсно ті зміни про які
сказав Дмитро вони реальні можливі але
для цього нам потрібно теж почути вашу
думку і потрібно ваша підтримка А чого
ви прагнете чого ви бажаєте і що би було
для вас цікавим і корисним Ми сьогодні
пробуємо побудувати нашу таку розмову і
яка складатиметься з двох частин
Спочатку ми хочемо попросити на наших
колег в голів керівників органів
учнівського самоврядування розказати про
ваш досвід
учнівського самоврядування та як ці
базові такі кроки до подальшої успішної
кар'єри потім ми трошки поговоримо з
вами про волонтерство і теж зрозуміємо В
чому суть і чим вона допомагає в
побудовій кар'єри і може бути корисною
загалом в житті для суспільства і далі в
нас буде такий етап питання відповіді
дискусії де ми з вами по дискутуємо про
взагалі життя буття у закладі
професійної освіти і я хочу звернутися
до наших спікерів нагадати що ми так
досить лімітовані по часу тому прохання
десь
навіть максимум 7 хвилин на вашу оповідь
розповідь можливо презентацію і тоді ми
переходимо переходимо далі Я з
задоволенням передаю слово
Гутник Людмилі учениці
великоновосілківського професійного
ліцею другий курс професія
кухар-кондитер І власне ми просимо вас
люди поділитися А яким сьогодні є
учнівське самоврядування в таких
непростих умовах Людмила вам слово
можете навіть будь ласка доступ для
демонстрації екрану
У нас є з цим проблемка скоріше за все
але я зараз спробую вам додати і скину
свою свій email ви можете скидати свою
презентацію
так немає в мене зараз можливості вам
надати доступ до екрану тому її Ви поки
що починаєте говорити А я вам тоді кидаю
свій email і ви відправляєте вашу
презентацію я скидаю Взагалі всі спікери
хто хочуть транслювати свої презентації
сьогодні Скиньте будь ласка на цей імейл
дякую
Людо ми вас не чуємо Зараз я скину
презентацію для вас Це я скинула ще раз
ще раз не в тих Ось так я розумію що
мені мої навички теж треба
удосконалювати тому що
можливо так
[музика]
я ось не завжди виходить так же ж мене
теж зробити адміністраторам я буду
трошки Я просто боюся що якщо у мене є
можливість тільки зробити когось хостом
і якщо я зараз зроблю когось хостом я
боюсь що ми потім не повернемось і
ми вже маємо такий досвід
бо немає кокоска
Добрий день всім учасникам круглого
столу Я годна Людмила учениця другого
курсу з професії кухар-кондитер велика
нависюківського професійного ліцею
Донецької області Тема моєї доповіді
учнівське самоврядування в умовах
сьогодення
учнівське самоврядування завжди була
невід'ємною складовою освітнього процесу
А зараз в умовах військової агресії
Російської Федерації проти України вона
набуває ще більшого значення звісно
постає питання як саме працювати просто
зараз як ростуть це таке підключилося це
вже дивлюся вона
я цим займаюсь Діма тому не можу
передати Перепрошую права хосту Бо знаю
як не просто менеджерити зустрічі на
200-300 людей людочку Продовжуйте я буду
максимально слідкувати там учнівського
самоврядування у великоновосілківському
професійному ліцеї завжди була
спланована так щоб сприяти встановленню
особистості як творця і про актуальне
життя
гармонізації та гуманізації стосунків
між учнями і педагогами навчальним
закладом і родиною
перехід на дистанційне навчання
зумовлений пандемією а потім її
активними військовими діями на території
волноваського району СМТ Велика
Новосілка
став неочікуваним та доволі серйозному
випробуванням для всіх учасників
освітнього процесу
педагогів учнів нашим батьків після
тимчасової розгубленості і всім довелося
прийняти це виклик так швидко
адаптуватися до нових реалій
якщо
2021-2022 навчальний рік ми закінчували
дещо розгубленими у зв’язку з тим що
відбулась евакуація нашого ліцею До
дніпропетровської області учнівський та
педагогічний колектив майже у повному
складі змінив місце проживання ми всі
роз'їхали це по різних куточках країни
та світу та новий
2022-2023 навчальний рік ми розпочали з
новими силами впевненістю у тому що ми
всі повинні наближати нашу перемогу
кожен на своєму місці
навчати і навчатись опановувати професію
бо зовсім скоро не до в Україні
знадобляться робітничі руки
важливо що члени ради учнівського
самоврядування виконавець луківського
професійного ліцею сприйняли цей виклик
як відкриття нових можливостей
маючи певний досвід роботи в
дистанційному режимі під час карантинних
обмежень учнівки самоврядування
продовжував свою роботу і під час
воєнного стану більш того маючи
лідерські якості активно життєву позицію
бурхливу юнацьку енергію прагнення до
дій та творчості Наші учні ставлення або
якою підтримкою для педагогів та своїх
одногрупників надихаючи всіх працювати з
новими силами та надіями на успіх
на початку вересня учнівським
самоврядуванням було проведено онлайн
засідання на якому ліцеїсти обговорили
та затвердили план дій підтвердили
повноваження голови учня третього курсу
професій кухар-кондитер Сергія Мотузко
та вийшло зі своїми пропозиціями щодо
подальшої роботи до адміністрації ліцею
Хочу зазначити що в нашому навчальному
закладі при складанні плану виховної
роботи від ціни навчальний рік
враховується пропозиції та ініціативи
здобувачів освіти щодо тематики та корм
проведення позакласних
загальнолюдейських заходів
учнівська самоврядування ліцею
організовує і проводить учасниками яких
є більшість учнів ліцею
наприклад спочатку нового навчального
року учні з великою зацікавленістю
долучились
загальнодержавного проекту між США не та
вдячності який присвячена вшануванню
подвигу захисників і захисників які
брали і зараз продовжують грати участь у
російсько-українській війні на сайті
нашого навчального закладу
представниками прес-центру була створена
сторінка з інформацією про техніку
знуків нашого ліцею який боронили та
боронять незалежність нашої країни за
ініціативи учнів ось центру деякі з них
були запрошені на виховні години
учасники учнівського самоврядування
разом із педагогічним працівниками
організовували різноманітні заходи до
визначних дат знакових подій брали
участь в обласних заходах наприклад
учасники комісії з фізкультури та спорту
взяли участь у козацьких забавах з
нагоди Дня захисників і захисниць
України та дня українського козацтва
у конкурсній програмі я майбутній
захисник України до Дня збройних сил які
були проведені Донецьким палацом молоді
Юність
провели онлайн челендж Разом до перемоги
Та я обираю стали активними учасниками
логін марафону Я за здоровий і чистий
спосіб життя
до дня української писемності ліцеїсти
взяли активну участь у виховному заході
ніхто не переможе Мій народ та
інтерактивній грі ми мовознавці
провели круглий стіл Мова - це наша
зброя і звісно всі разом написали
диктант національної єдності
до Дня гідності та свободи взяли участь
в обласному тематичному заході гідні
бути українцями та вікторині кризи
Конституція Гранд гідності та Свободи 20
січня 2023 року команда великана
Васильківського професійного ліцею
долучили до тематичного спілкування та
інтерактивного квесту Україна
починається з тебе
ліцеїсти з великим задоволенням брали
участь в інтерактивних завданнях де мали
змогу виявити креативне мислення
гартованість і творчість
у дистанційному форматі активно працює і
художній самодіяльність ліцею учні
знімають та монтують різноманітні
відеоролики беруть участь у поетичних
конкурсах створюють інтерактивні плакати
малюють та співають
і звісно мріють ЗНО повернутися до
актових зали ліцею щоб всім разом як і
раніше відзначати свята на затишній
сцені відчути гучні або від смерті
глядачів а поки ми беремо участь у
багатьох заходах онлайн-форматів але з
найменшого за якістю тому творчий
колектив здобувачів освіти ліцею як і
раніше отримує заслужені на городі в
різноманітних конкурсах наприклад
команда ліцею екопатруль здобула
декілька призових місць у відкритому
обласному дистанційному фестивалі
збережи екосвіт Донеччини
активно працює і комісія з дисципліни та
порядку Наші учні беруть активну участь
моніторинг відвідування навчальних
занять за спеціальних стипендіальної
комісії та учнівської профспілки
за ініціативою ради учнів учнівського
самоврядування та підтримці колективу
велику на Васильківського професійного
ліцею до дня Святого Миколая був
організований збір коштів для придбання
запасних частин для військових
автомобілів за запитом захисників нашого
волноваського району 105 батальйону
тарілон також рада учнівського
самоврядування здобувачів освіти ліцею
активно довели вчилась до волонтерської
діяльності
учні які знайшли себе в самоврядування і
дійсно змінюють життя навчального
закладу міста А у майбутньому внесуть
нові зміни і в державі Прикладом цього
може бути випускник нашого ліцею Горбаль
Ярослав який під час навчання був
головою учнівського самоврядування ліцею
потім головою студентської ради
бердянського державного педагогічного
університету членом молодіжної ради при
бердянській міській раді у 2020 році
переможцем у номінації студент вітер
студентського самоврядування року
у 2022 здобув перемогу над честь
студентів спільний діяч року зараз
залишається активним учасником багатьох
значущих заходів або бути громадянином
відповідальний організатором тому в
чайцями дитячі і юнацькі об'єднання
не можу не сказати і про те що колектив
нашого ліцею напередодні тижня в
професійної освіти отримав гран-прі у
рейтинговому конкурсі виставки сучасні
заклади освіти у номінації професійна
професійно-технічна освіта України
наш час потребує лідерів нової
інформації людей компетентних
відповідальних здатних мислити
неординарні
генерувати нові ідеї та обирати у
нестандартні рішення
наш навчальний заклад виконали
сілківський професійний ліцей підтримує
учнівську молодь чи я життєва позиція
спрямована на активну участь у
громадському житті молодь має
організаторські здібності усвідомлює
себе лідером розуміє що великі справи
починаються із маленьких вчинків
бажаю Що учнівське самоврядування це
старт для початку професійного зростання
можливості вчитися бути відповідальним
для себе і за інших Дякую за увагу
Тепер у мене я сподіваюсь люди що на
останніх хвилинах Мені вдалося Все ж
таки показати вашу презентацію
сподіваюся що її було видно якщо не було
видно Ви мені скажіть бо я тут теж
навчаюся разом з вами Бо я з конвою ще
не працювала А у вас презентація
підготовлена в канві Дуже дякую а
найголовніше Мабуть що хочеться сказати
Те що ми не перестаємо захоплюватися
власним мужність у мужністю знаєте що
так зараз не заплакати
нашої молодості молоді і мужність у
наших колег колег освітян які незважаючи
ні на що незважаючи на такі складні
умови дійсно продовжують працювати а
найголовніше що тримають зв'язок одне з
одним підтримують і вам вдається зробити
просто неймовірні речі я знаю що дякую
Людо залишаємося тут якщо будуть питання
повторю Як ви можете їх писати в чаті
безпосередньо до Людмили або на загал ми
будемо їх розглядати я бачила що мені на
пошту прийшла презентація від єфима з
Чернівецького вищого професійного
училища радіоелектроніки тому є фільм
Якщо ви з нами
я вас не одразу ідентифікувала то я тобі
даю вам слово і зараз включаю вашу
презентацію така ось вона така
зелененька зараз я її але ви можете вже
починати говорити
Доброго дня я говорю Вітаю всіх Вибачте
можу трохи потислах бо а хвилююсь
[музика]
що видно вашого презентацію тому поїхали
Да ми мого проекту учнівська
самоврядування як засіб формування
життєвих компетентностей долучив освіти
дальше
мотиваційним кремом учнівської ради є
зібратися разом за початок триматися
разом це прогрес
працювати разом це успіх
хотів би зауважити
на сучасному етапі розвитку суспільства
пріоритетним є виховання соціально
активної творчої
компетентної особистості яка генерує
нові ідеї приймає нестандартні рішення
нові реалії вимагають від молоді
динамізму гнучкості поведінки уміння
швидко змінювати стратегію діяльності
адаптуватися до змін соціальних ролей
вміти поєднувати особисті корпоративні
інтереси
саме тому учнівське самоврядування
забезпечує здобувачам освіти володіння
ключовими життєвими компетенціями
розвиває мотивація до навчання та
успішної кар'єри до саморозвитку
самовдосконалення розвиває лідерські
якості формує навички активної
громадянської позиції
учнівська рада Чернівецька вийшов
професійному училищі радіоелектроніки
створений представницький координуючий
орган здобуваючи освітлених послуг дії
на підставі положення про учнівську Раду
що приймається на конференції здобувачів
освіти затверджується директором училища
метою Чернігівського самоврядування є
формування і розвиток соціального
активної творчої інтелектуально
розвиненої духовної моральною зрілої
особистості з глибокої усвідомленою
громадянською позицією почуттям
справедливості та стійкості
самосвідомості
учнівська рада складається з президента
віце-президента голів комітетів
секретаря учнівська рада формує її
затверджує склад комітетів таких як
комітет запитань партнерства та
міжнародних відносин імітація запитань
захисту прав здоров'я чи освіти та
допомоги проблемних ситуаціях комітет
загальноосвітньої та професійної
підготовки комітет Комітет преса та
інформації комітет спорту та здорового
способу життя комітет культури та
дозвілля комітет комінтерського руху
кожен кандидат має свої конкретні
завдання та функції зокрема Комітет з
питань партнерства та міжнародних
відносин наголошує партнерські відносини
з різноманітними громадянськими
організаціями
амбасадорами закладу та реалізації
освітніх проектів участі у різноманітних
заходах акціях
лідери Чернівецького вищого професійного
училища радіоелектроніки долучилися до
програми компанії від junier Чилі
очевимент та організували свою
міні-компанію водворуд конструктор
створили екологічний та пізнавальний
пазл конструктор з усіма країнами світу
а також додали до кожного виробу
унікальний qr-коди останній місяць
інформація про Кожний з регіонів який є
на конструкторі
і представляли свою продукцію я на
ярмарку в місті Львові і успішно
реалізували свою продукцію
навчальні також були проведені навчання
тренінги в рамках співпраці з
міжнародною
природою Чернівецької області
один із них - це до Всесвітнього дня
боротьби зі СНІДом
комітет запитань захисту прав здобувачів
освіти та допомоги проблемних ситуаціях
проводить просвітницьку до роботи з
питань вивчення правил залучив
протидії різним формам насильства
організували училище довіри
10 вересня проводиться проводяться
заходи до Всесвітнього дня запобігання
самогубства та гаслом я обираю життя
спільний з представниками поліції
в рамках заходів всеукраїнської компанії
16 днів проти насильства благодійний
фонд проката підвів підсумки акції стоп
насильства Наша команда отримала
перемогу у номінації відеоролики
руйнуємо гендерні стереотипи фотосесія
різні Але рівні
комітет та
загальноосвітніми та професійної
підготовки
співпрацьовує з педагогами майстрами
виробничого навчання щодо участі
здобувачів освіти різноманітних
Всеукраїнських регіональних конкурсах в
касової майстерності учнівських
конференціях предметах олімпіадах і за
загальноосвітніх та професійних при
постійних підготовки
[музика]
також було проведено знання з елементами
тренінгу для здобучів освітніх послуг на
тему які навички провела виховний
совсери Тетяна Мандзюк
лідер голосіївської ради взяли участь у
національному технічному вебінарі
лідерство у сфері фільтрації також учні
призери всеукраїнського спеціалізованого
конкурсу професійної майстерності сервіс
майстер в зоні 2023
отримали чимало призів як для себе так і
для закладу також був проведений конкурс
професійний талант року
комітет преса та інформація нагороджує
зв'язки та співпрацю з редакціями газет
журналів радіо та телепрограма для
учнівської молоді проводить
соціологічного опитування щодо вивчення
громадської думки про неї актуальніші
теми для підлітків
також цей комітет знімав різні
відеоролики які ви тепер бачите на
слайді можете прийти за посиланням та
подивитись
Я думаю ми поділимося вашими
презентаціями якщо вони будуть
заперечувати бо я бачу що ми трошки
маємо пришвидшитися по часу тому їх Ми
продовжуємо
також про орієнтаційні відеоролики тож
на слайді або йдемо далі
у комітет спорту та здоров'я на слайді
все написано не було затримувати йдемо
далі
це з спортивне змагань в яких брали
участь наші силуючі освіти можете
подивитися
комітет культури та дозвілля також
всього написано йдемо далі щоб не
затримувати
цікавими формами роботи є квести
вікторини екскурсії майстер-класи
і флешмоб
комітет волонтерського руху Це тепер
дуже поширена тема під час такого стану
який є в Україні організовує проведення
благодійних ярмарків класів з метою
збору коштів продуктів харчування
засобів особистої гігієни для
військовослужбовців внутрішньо
переміщеним особам
тут збирали українські книжки проходили
до не благополучних діти які постраждали
під час війни чи ще десь у світі то є
жертвало багато чого
письмовуючи можна певно стверджувати що
учнівська самоврядування потрібне і
важливий для здобувачів освіти
Дякую за увагу
Дякую
я гортаючи Вашу презентацію власне
хотіла якраз уточнити у вас таке питання
ви сказали що заклад є активним
учасником джунія речіпмент Я знаю що це
певний проєкт який розвиває
підприємницький здібності
учнів А скажіть будь ласка ви особисто
брали участь в цій команді переможців чи
можливо ваша команда якимось іншим
проектом займалася
я брав у відбірковому етапі участь а в
самому конкурсі я не дійшов не хватило
пару балів прийшов другий курс
вони виграла Окей А тоді наступне
запитання Як ви вважаєте чи цікавий
взагалі подібний формат і Чи треба нам
подібні заходи та і подібні проекти
продовжувати Я вважаю що так було доволі
інтересно і вважаєш це треба розвивати і
робити побільше таких конкурсів
якщо у когось будуть виникати запитання
Я впевнена вони нам їх поставлять у
чатик бачу вже великі подяки за так за
іспити так Я поо отримувала купу
презентацій зараз їх потрошку завантажую
і до слова
запрошую ученицю Сумського вищого
професійного училища у будівництва і
дизайну за професією візажист перукар До
речі в нас сьогодні представлена Вся
Україна і фактично одна і різноманітніші
професії Валерію майбороду Валерію Я
зараз теж поширю вашу презентацію тому
переймайте ініціативу на себе Доброго
дня
Вітаю всіх присутніх Мене звати Валерія
я успішно здобуваю професію візажист
перукар дає президентом учнівського
самоврядування у сумському вищому
професійному училищі будівництва і
дизайну Я представляю найбільше місто
північної Слобожанщини місто Суми
заснування пов'язане з подіями
визвольної війни українського народу під
проводом Богдана Хмельницького у 1652
році тут живуть надзвичайно сміливі і
рішучі люди які не пустили руський мир у
місто росіянам не вдалося окупувати
місто однак воно було в облозі 44 дні
Сумська земля славиться просто
неймовірною культурою храму святим
літературними діячами музеями театрами
це унікальне славетна земля ми дуже
щасливі що тут живемо сьогодні як Ніколи
ми повинні бути хоробрими і сміливими
розуміти що є Лише в єдності і
згуртованості український народ переможе
ворогам своєю творчістю добрими справами
ми робимо свій внесок у наближення
Перемоги і з гордістю промовляємо Я
українець Я українка наш девіз Пропонуй
плануй організовуй виконують
співпрацюємо ми на таких
як словом так і ділом честі і совісті
дружби і товариськості турботи і
милосердям У сучасних умовах де все
відбувається в цифровому середовищі
найбільшим викликом для нас є робота над
іміджем закладу у цьому році ми провели
творчий конкурс на створення нового
логотипу закладу
візуальної ідентичність є важлива
частина брендингу і створює єдність усіх
комунікаційних матеріалах візуальна
ідентичність - це основний і
найважливіший елемент фірмового стилю
нашого закладу і основою візуальної
ідентифікації
також свій творчий потенціал ми
направили на створення унікального
відеоконтенту відео контент вважається
одним із
найперспективніших інструментів
комунікації відео зручний тим що
сприймається простіше і краще за
текстовий формат а свій унікальний
контент Ми розміщуємо на сайті
електронних сторінках закладу у
соціальних мережах ми творчі підходимо
до цього питання і створюємо
різноманітні відео уроки іміджеві ролики
формують емоційне ставлення аудиторії до
закладу професійної професійно-технічної
освіти
презентаційні ролики головна мета
продемонструвати освітні послуги або
готовий продукт зроблений саме нашими
руками
вірусні уроки в першу чергу це той
відеоконтент який привертає увагу ролик
називають вірусними Коли людина
заражається переданою ідеєю і згодом у
неї виникає бажання поділитися вірусом
далі а ще вчимося бути активними
громадянами ми учасниками проекту для
дітей
десятимісячна програма тренінгове занять
направлена на розвиток
трансляцію Ось так у нас завжди буває на
зубах Я повертаюся Я перепрошую Валерія
ми трошки перервалися але я зараз знову
повернуся до трансляції екрану вашої
презентації Продовжуйте
ми створили клуб посередині для розвитку
де нам комфортно ділитися думками та
обрані на обрані теми брати участь у
обговореннях та взаємодіяти один з одним
назва нашої команди активні акулятори
щомісячні зустрічі з покращенням м'яких
навичок Soft Skills Ця програма
передбачає заняття за темою
стресостійкість гнучкість комплексне
вирішення проблем та ідеал критичне
мислення та аналіз реактивність
оригінальність та ініціативність навичка
навчання впродовж життя
вміння переконувати та вести переговори
вміння публічних виступів міжкультурна
комунікація такі навички як критичне
мислення аналітичне мислення вирішення
проблем творчість робота в команді вміти
спілкуватись Та проводити переговори
прийняття рішень саморегуляції стійкість
емпатія участь повага до різноманітності
враховуються усі ключовий
компетентностях ми розуміємо що такі
навички потрібні для особистої
реалізації та розвитку активного
громадського життя соціальної єдності та
можливості працевлаштування активна
життєва та громадська позиція - це
антипод байдужості і відстороннього
активна життєва позиція насамперед
передбачає діяльність Україна за 15
місяців великої війни стало символом
незламності та боротьби за свободу для
усього цивільного
цивілізованого світу ми пишаємося бути
українцями ми єдині у баченні умов миру
і майбутнього України ми одностайно
підтримуємо
територіальну цілісність України
навчаємося робітничим професіям щоб
відбудувати свою рідну країну і жити
саме тут
щоб відчути себе українцем мало
народитися і жити в Україні треба ще й
вивчати історію свого народу лось звичай
і побут мовою культуру і не лише
створеної і митцями а йду що викликане з
дітей прадіда
передана нам їхніми нащадками як
неоцінений спарк кожні місто має свою
історію свої спогади свої загадкові
таємниці є такі таємниці як куточки і в
нашому рідному місті і ми почали
досліджувати такі куточки наш
історико-право краєзнавчий проект ніс
місто більш минулий у майбутньому про
кадетський міст символ стійкості рідного
міста міст - це частина козацької
містечка яке було гордістю та окраскою
широкі хвилі
шукаю
пізніше тут була артилерійська школа
згодом військовий інститут артилерії при
сумському державному університеті А
потім ліцеї з посиленою
військово-фізичною підготовкою імені
Івана таратойника кадетський корпус став
справжнім
міста ворог кілька разів прагнув
прорвати нам оборону але так і не зміг
зараз випускники Сумського міського
навчального закладу захищають рідну
батьківщину спочатку війни саме
волонтерська діяльність у закладі
об'єднана наш колектив небайдужа
громадян переселенців з перших днів наш
заклад опинився в авангарді
волонтерського руху ми допомагали у
виготовленні військового спорядження за
цей період було відшито три з половиною
тисячі одиниць виробів а саме розгрузка
плитоноски балаклави шеврони
розгрузочний пояс системи і тд
виготовлено всім 275 сіток це
6523 м² до вашої улюблениці налякані
війною теж не залишилося без уваги ми
стежимо за ситуацією в притулках
забезпечуємо їх кормом проповідуємо
дбайливе ставлення до тварин та активної
пухнастими та перемогами А ще ми даруємо
частину наших сердець славно воїнам
захисникам для гарного настрою та
підняття бойового духу дівчата нашого
закладу виготовляли паперових янголочки
охоронців і інші обереги
наші Відважна Захисники нехай
ангел-охоронить береже ваші відчуття у
такі складні часи Ми хочемо не припиняти
творити працювати над добротом закладів
і створювати посмішки у тих хто поруч з
нами хотілось спрямована наповнюємо свої
думки позитивом думаємо про творчі
задачі про нові проекти Звісно що в нас
є надбання і помилку з якими проходить
досвід
закладено підвалину великої справи Ми
творимо історію своєї країни і робимо
свій маленький вклад у Великому перемогу
Дякую за увагу
дякую дякую вам Валерій є було дуже
цікаво найголовніше те що ви всі
асоціюєте себе з місцем Де проживаєте
надзвичайно теж було ще мливо коли учні
з маріупольського одного закладів
професійної освіти писали до нас
звернення до Міністерства і казали що ми
хочемо закінчити саме Цей заклад саме
заклад такий ми обрали серцем саме
заклад в Маріуполі кабач Як ви любите
рідне місто і я зараз передаю із
задоволенням слово Софії тибенко
сосновська вище професійне училище
лісового господарства Я знаю що сновськ
це місто на півночі півночі нашої країни
і теж розумію що ви були налякані на
початку війни І власне хочеться почути
як зараз
триває ваш шлях і розвиток і зауважити
що сновськ До речі це один із тих
закладів закладу Сумський де ми
збираємося робити Центр професійної
досконалості тому Софія я не буду
показувати ваше відео бо поки була
трансляція я подивилася Я думаю що воно
буде задовге там ще 3 хвилини але зараз
передаю вам слово і починаю вашу
презентацію прошу
презентую чернігівщину і якщо можна
презентація запустити знайти вже ці своє
місце свою справу завдання не просте Я
часто задумувалась над цим питанням що в
шкільні роки прислухавшись до свого
серця зрозуміла що хочу бути кухарем і
вступила до сновського вищого
професійного училища лісового
господарства яке є одним з кращих в
області підготовці висококваліфікованих
робітників за цією спеціальністю
доторкнувшись до мистецтва приготування
їжі я ще більше зацікавилася цим фахом а
усвідомлений вибір майбутньої професії
це і є шлях до Мрії крім навчання є з
головою поринулась громадське життя
закладу хотілося відчути себе лідером а
потім всього колективу закладу сім'ї я
поступово почала втілювати на першому
курсі вона брала старостою групу потім
була мова ви президента закладу освіти
згодом здобула перемогу на посаду
президента обласної ради учнівського
самоврядування в закладів про техосвіти
Чернігівщина на цьому посту я змогла ще
більше Показати своє лідерські здібності
та розвивати їх надалі паралельно всім
як вдосконалювала свою професійну
майстерність кухаря-кондитера
гарне кухар це творець справжній ювелір
що створює кулінарний шедевр і це
найбільше мене мотивує та надихає
також беру активну участь у житті
училища у національному парку екологічну
це та сама Марина Раєвська
пані Марино я просто вимушена постійно
припиняти бо є ще не навчилася Так пані
Марино Раєвська Я вас дуже прошу не
вмикайте будь ласка ви заважаєте нашій
молоді дякую
продовжуємо софієчку Та я зараз ще раз
поширюю екран
Якщо можете пишні з 9-10 слайда також
беру активну участь у житті училища у
національну патріотичних екологічних
профілів реабілітаційних проєктах
виховних годинах засідання бібліотечного
клубу та інше моя Громадянська позиція
привела малим волонтерство а згодом у
молодіжну Раду сам яка активно діє у
сновських громад сьогодні в Україні
волонтерство насамперед асоціюється з
допомогою армії Але воно не обмежується
лише підтримкою військових це увага до
тих хто поруч зокрема дітей благодійна
допомога стосується підтримки людей
уважного віку участі в акції допомоги
внутрішньо переміщеним особам та
багатьом інших безкорисливих справ
у поняття успішний лідер кожна вкладає
щось своє а для мене це той хто
маленькими кроками наближається до своєї
мрії вірить у перемогу розвиває свій
професіоналізм впевнена що обране серцем
спеціальність та посада президента
учнівського самоврядування стане
підґрунтям Тараса для самореалізації і
обов'язково включаєте про мене як про
бренд шефа А можливо і нова страва
носитиме Моє ім'я Мрії збуваються Дякую
за увагу
Дякую Софія але знаєте тут так прикольно
чути від вас що ви хочете новим
планшетом буде в нас є один Амбасадор
професійної освіти
котрого збито Євген Клопотенко то я так
думаю що можна передати Жені що йому вже
гарно наступають на п'ятий і що дуже
швидко Софія нас здивує я дійсно щиро я
думаю що ми всі
вважаємо вам успіху і
переходимо передаємо естафету наразі
регіональному центру професійної освіти
луганського національного університету
імені Тараса Шевченка
воробйовій кирині кариночко будь ласка я
зараз
відкриваю вашу презентацію здається вона
в мене десь тут поруч якщо ви мене чуєте
то будь ласка вам слово зараз
чи можна буде я вам буду казати
наступний слайд І ви будете так як вам
зручно так ми будемо робити Я вже її
включаю і поїхали Всім доброго дня мене
звати Воробйова Каріна я навчаюсь
відокремленому підрозділі регіональний
Центр професійної освіти державного
закладу Луганський національний
університет імені Тараса Шевченка
на третьому курсі да професію перукар
перукар-модельєр манікюрний педикюрник
наступний слайд
Я хочу розказати про моє кар'єрне
зростання 4:0 Чому 4:0 Тому що це нова
ера розвитку технологій технології і
бізнесу яка змінює спосіб працювати і
розвиватися я зрозуміла що важливим
елементом кар'єрного зростання 4.0 є
гнучкість і адаптивність ринок праці
швидко змінюється Тому потрібно бути
готовим до змін і вміти пристосовуватись
до нових умов я відкрита до викликів і
можливості і готова навчатися чомусь
новому наступний слайд
після дев'ятого класу ми не стало
питання Коли далі куди й далі йти
навчатися для себе я обрала професійну
освіту тому що вона найкраще відповідала
ми їм цілям і інтересам це шлях до
швидкого отримання професії та старту
кар'єри ще однією з переваг професійної
освіти є можливість отримати безоплатне
навчання та стипендію що дозволяє
зосередитися на навчання не турбуючись
про фінансові витрати крім того моя
професія перукар - це іміджева та
креативна професія де творчість та
індивідуальний стиль грають важливу роль
професійна освіта в цій галузі допомагає
розвинути необхідні навички таланти
відкриває шлях до успіху бажаній сфері
діяльності наступний слайд
закінчуючи навчання в цьому році та
проходячи безліч тренерів майстер-класів
я здобула як Hard Skills такі Soft
Skills що дуже важливо в цій галузі я
володіла навичками з роботи жіночими та
чоловічими стрижками волоссям різної
структури та довжини Також я вивчила
техніки фарбування використання кератину
табутоксу окрім того я вмію створювати
різноманітні зачіски включаючи весільні
вечірні коктельні повсякденні тематичні
Також я володіла мистецтвом мистецтва
манікюру та педікюру навчилися робити
корекцію брів щоб допомагати клієнтам
підтримати доглянутий вид під час
навчання та проходження практики в
салоні краси я здобула навички роботи в
команді де креативела готуючись до
конкурсів окрім того мобільність та
ініціативність грають важливу роль у
моєї професії Я готова працювати в
різних місцях включаючи студії краси
салони тощо ініціативність дозволяє мені
постійно вдосконалюватися вивчати нові
техніки та тренди в індустрії краси
наступний слайд але почалась війна
деякий час я перебувала в окупації потім
вже таки виїхала до Нідерландів і тут я
дізналась що в мене загинув брат який
служив в лавах ЗСУ який боронив наш
рідний край і який загинув на моє день
народження Слава Україні Героям слава
наступний слайд
Сьогодні я навчаюсь дистанційно взагалі
я дуже активна дівчина завжди беру
участь в різних конкурсах олімпіадах
заходах концертах наприклад я призерка з
різних предметів у другому етапі
Всеукраїнських учнівських олімпіад з
української мови і літератури та
біології також посіла перше місце в
другому етапі міжнародного
мовно-літературного конкурсу учнівської
та студентської молоді імені Тараса
Шевченка друге місце в другому етапі
міжнародного конкурсу з української мови
імені Петра Яцика перш ніж місце
обласного етапу 12 всеукраїнському
конкурсі учнівської творчості номінації
українська література на тему народ мій
є народ мій завжди буде ніщо не
перекреслить Мій народ
брала участь у між обласному Марафоні на
з'єднаємо вам 25 травня відбудеться
Всеукраїнське віртуальний арт-просторів
ми разом ми стильні ми України в якому я
також беру участь А особливо мені
подобалось подобалося готуватися до
конкурсу популярності обрати зачіску
модель придумувати образи креативи та
експериментувати
перебуваючи в Нідерландах я дуже
засмутилася що не зможу працювати в
своїй сфері бо я зрозуміла що я не знаю
голландської мови але випадково одна
жіночка Сказала що їй по триварній я
пішла на співбесіду Це був барбершоп
капсалон мобіформ спілкуючись
англійською та через Google перекладач я
успішно пройшла співбесідом хоча це був
чоловічий салон але до мене на стрижки
прийшли почали ходити жінки на даний час
ми її послуги розширюються бо паралельно
я роблю фарбування волосся кератин та
Ботокс різні зачіски укладки корекцію
брів манікюр педікюр чого раніше в цьому
закладі не було для мене ці процеси
справжніми мистецтво люди прагнуть до
красивими А я в цьому їм допомагаю
наступний слайд
моє майбутнє виглядає обіцяючи після
закінчення мого улюбленого закладу
освіти повернення в Україну стане першим
кроком до здійснення моєї мрії про
власний салон але це не просто один
салон Я мрію про мережу салонів також в
планах є відкрити навчальний б'юті-центр
Де я зможу передати свої знання та
дозвіл в наступному поколінню фахівців Я
вірю в значення освіти протягом усього
життя тому я сама постійно буду
навчатися вдосконалюватися та
розширювати свої професійні навички моя
мета стати суперовим фахівцем галузі
краси я буду продовжувати вдосконалювати
свої Hard Skills такі Soft Skills
навчатися новим технологіям трендом Та
інноваціям я прагну стати експертом який
здатний задовільнити будь-які потреби
своїх клієнтів та робити кожну особу
впевненою та красивою наступний слайд
Отже моя кар'єрне зростання - це
навчатися працювати експериментувати
рости ризикувати порушувати правила і
робили помилки та йти вперед Дякую за
увагу
і поки я повертаюся додому Дякую Каріно
ваша історія вона просто не може не
вражати і дійсно хочеться сказати вічно
свого Героям нашим захисникам
не просто а дбати про своє майбутнє як
думати Це Це просто надзвичайно складно
в мене все ще є прохання все ж таки З
повагою ставитися до наших учнів і
Шановні колеги наші методисти викладачі
які долучилися що ви займаєтеся власними
справами то краще відключатися від цієї
зустрічі Бо нам ще є що поговорити і що
представити Каріна я вам Бажаю успіху і
я бажаю вам якнайшвидшего повернення в
Україну і я готова приходити до вас в
салони на стрижки і не тільки на стрижки
Я думаю що учасники сьогоднішньої
зустрічі маю таку саму думку а
передається наша естафета далі в складне
місто Рівне Рівненський центр
професійно-техні діти сервісу та дизайну
до Степанець Вікторії Вікторія в нас
заступник голови учнівського
самоврядування Вікторію ви вже Можете
починати говорити А я зараз перевіряю чи
в мене була ваша презентація і
презентації немає І це невеличка
Тоді Давайте почнемо з вашої доповіді
Доброго дня Мене звати Вікторія я
заступник голови учнівської ради
навчались державному
професійно-технічному навчальному
закладі
Рівненський центр професійно-технічної
освіти сервісу та дизайну де крім мене
навчається 570 моїх друзів і щорічно ми
маємо конкурс два-три вступники на одне
місце
кожна дитина коли
закінчує школу вибирає свою професію
і Для кожного цей вибір дуже складний
так як я багато закладів професій тому
Вони дуже часто не знають що хочуть Куди
вони хочуть погодьтесь
тому Вони вибирають просто освіти але з
часом вони розуміють що все одне і з
найкращих рішень в їхньому житті
на сьогодні Рівненщина як телева область
має змогу надавати учням навчатися
безпосередньо виробничих майстернях
вживу та навчально-практичних центрах
які мають
надсучасне обладнання
величезний вибір професії та закладів
сучасні бази для навчання та цікаве
дозвілля а також є великий попит на
наших випускників закладу профтехосвіти
у нашому регіоні
більшість навчальних закладів направляє
випускників на роботу для подальшого
працевлаштування
у закладі про в тих освіти Рівненщини
учні можуть самостверджуватися також
окрім навчання займатися різними видами
творчої зайнятості брати участь у житті
про в тих освіти та її покращення
треба займатися волонтерством і допомоги
нашим воїнам так як це йде одна із
головних цілей В теперішній час
а також учнівське самоврядування є
головним важелем в житті учнів в закладі
учні
[музика]
вському санчились
комунікуватись співпрацювати делегувати
та виконувати різні обов'язки А ще у
мене є особиста мрія втілити
тобто створити
свій бренд білизни Я уже навчаюсь
паралельно працюю Після навчання на
величезну підприємстві на Альона
комбінаті
і поєднується з цим уже збираю
невеличкий капітал
І до речі Багато наших українських
бізнесменів починалося саме з
профтехосвіти Тому треба задуматися
це загалом запрошую усіх до нас на
навчання у нашій заклади про техосвіти
це стане успішним початком вашої
професійної кар'єри і у нас дуже круто
весело
дякую
дуже вам дякую Вікторія власне Ми
нещодавно були на Рівненщині і можемо з
Дмитром Так точно підтвердити наскільки
потужні заклади професійної освіти і
більше того учора на нашій на нашому
телеграм-каналі І власне в нашій
Фейсбуці сторінці теж Ми розмістили
відеоролик про заклади Рівненщини
сподіваємося що протягом всього року
навичок і європейського якийсь стартував
нещодавно 9 травня ми такі ролики будемо
мати про кожну область і зможемо
похвалитися дійсно найбільшими вашими
досягненнями і здобутками дякую віку за
відвертість Дякую за те що Розумієте як
важливо заробляти вже сьогодні Та і
власне можете про це сміливо сказати що
це мабуть добре мати власні кошти і
самостійно себе забезпечувати
аніж просто
думати і чекати чогось кращого від життя
це мабуть те що сьогодні єднає нас
українців і допомагає нам виборювати
нашу перемогу
і ми зараз переходимо до такого блоку
плавно бо ви е-е майже всі наші е-е
виступаючи до цього торкалися теми
волонтерства зараз так хочемо поговорити
про теж досвід учнівського
самоврядування у волонтерстві навіть в
нас тут є от наступний виступаючий
презентатор молодіжним амбасадорство
тому
запрошую до слова мою землячку
Сподіваюся бо це Дніпропетровський Центр
професійної освіти А я з Дніпра
лишневського Анастасію Анастасію беріть
слово В мене вже є завантажена ваша
презентація Я зараз її відкрию
так Анастасія ви тут бо я знаю що ви
були
чи чути нас Настю ми вас не чуємо
Окей тоді Настя відпишіть мені будь
ласка в особисті якщо Вам вдалося
перепідключитися і є вже звичок А я тоді
передаю слово яні Ковальський Яночку
десь мала вивантаженою вашу презентацію
Тому зараз підключусь
А ви нас чуєте Зараз чую
Настя Настя повернулася тому Яночко
чекаємо поки Настя повернулася і будь
ласка Настю вам слово Доброго дня Вітаю
голова учнівського самоврядування
Дніпровського центру професійної освіти
ярошницька Анастасія навчаюсь на другому
курсі за професією Кравець за клімок і
незважаючи на те що вимушені навчатися
дистанційно ми все одно продовжуємо жити
нашим нормальним студентським життям в
центрі діє учнівської ради яка була
обрана на початку навчального року ми
розробили план
нашої діяльності і реалізуємо його
протягом року на слайді ви бачите
структуру нашої ради учнівського
учнівське самоврядування в нашому
закладі існує багато років члени входять
до складу ступінь ідеальної комісії
профілактики ради
організо це звільня займається у гуртках
художній самодіяльності та спортивних
секціях гучність групах на початку
навчального року також обираємо Актив і
формуємо учнівську Раду в групи
виявляємо
пропозиції танці ініціативу бочкових
групах та обираємо
обговорюємо їх на засідання Ради
самоврядування разом з педагогами ми
організуємо і проводимо різні заходи
челленджі конкурсу Вікторії ми готуємось
до Джури наступні слайди будь ласка там
із показано який ми разом з іншими
радами самоврядуванням це вогонь Миру
також разом з педагогами ми організуємо
підготовкою до жири приймаємо участь у
міжнародних проєктах тоді як відкрити
освітні кафе Це український проект Де ми
обговорювали питання Що є спільними для
учнів різних професій та національностей
а також на
у 2021 році ми приймали участь у
польсько-українському проекті будуємо
спільноту заради розвитку українського
самоврядування в Україні вносили свої
пропозиції до хартії демократичного
учнівського самоврядування в Україні
Тобто ми маємо вплив на прийняття
спільного рішення
це корисний досвід але наша діяльність
зараз в основному направлена на
волонтерство Ми продовжуємо традицію
учнівського самоврядування в минулих
років разом з адміністрацією беремо
участь у колективній справі ми як всі
українці бажаємо Перемоги і очікуємо
миру і це нелегкий час багато хто
потребує допомоги
це і наші Захисники і люди які вимушено
вимушені покинули свої домівки і люди
похилого віку і тварини усі тому ми
як можемо допомагаємо Ми виготовляємо
постійні білизни та рушники для воєнного
шпиталю футболки для поранення беремо
участь у акціях таких як зігрі воїна та
подарує від це свято
збираємо продукти харчування смаколики
та ліки виготовляємо окупні свічки
виготовляємо прапора та відправляємо їх
до військових також шиємо наші
закрійники ми ну і на практиці і в
закладі ми шиємо плащі намети тактичні
сумки
теплобілизну для бійців на замовлення
міжнародного центру підтримки України
також ми беремо участь у волонтерській
роботі з формування пакетів гуманітарної
допомоги приготування їжі для
постраждалих збір коштів на акумулятори
для військових надання тимчасового житла
для ВПУ
і також ми приймали участь в акті
сміливих гривні і порадили всі збірні
кошти Національному банку України А ще
ми чітко розуміємо що після війни нам
треба буде розбито розбудовувати державу
нашу рідну дніпропетровщину а також
Україну тому ми розуміємо що це будемо
саме Ми молодь яка має професію яка
готова до змін та різних виборків готова
будувати кар'єру відкривати підприємства
в нашому закладі функціонує центр
кар'єри які йому відкрили у минулому
році рада учнівського самоврядування
активно приймає участь у його діяльність
Ми не даємо консультації школярам
проводимо майстер-класи розробляємо
постери навчаємось на тренінгах після
тренінгів за програмою ми проводимо
заняття для наших одногрупників ми
виступаємо на батьківських зборах
заплановані Запрошуємо наших успішних
випускників які у форматі живе в
Бібліотекарі діляться тому що я був
побудові успішної кар'єри також
виступаємо на обласному радіус створюємо
відеоролик із професійних майстер-класів
і розповсюджуємо їх у соцмережі
приймаємо участь у проведенні днів
відкритих дверей
Таким чином ми активно розповсюджуємо
інформацію з пропаганди не робітничих
професій навчаємось самі і навчаємось
навчаємо інших наші гасло успішна людина
успішна країна
тому
можете до кінця
догортати тому так як зараз ще проходить
тиждень просто освіти Ми підготували не
мали заходів і будемо реалізовувати їх
тому Бажаю всім успіху Перемоги і слава
Україні
героям слава я надзвичайно вам дякую
Анастасії за те що включилися І хочу
сказати що моя найкраща подруга
насправді закінчила навчальний заклад
вона на Сьогодні має свій бізнес
починаючи зі звичайної швої потім
працювала з олійником зараз має свій
бізнес і є дуже успішною Я хочу сказати
що вона купила собі автомобіль вже давно
а є до цих пір'ї немає І це свідчить про
те що мати в руках гарний факт це завжди
запорука успіху тому я вважаю вам теж
успіху Я думаю що ви надихнулися в тому
числі і от відвідуючи Академію Андре
Тана
дійсно дуже такі різноманітні професії я
отримую шалене задоволення від того як
ви ділитеся своїми враженнями від того
як ви навчаєтеся і так я ж теж тут
знаєте здобуваю нові скіли не завжди в
мене це гарно виходить особливо
перемикатися між різними вікнами Але я
думаю що далі наша естафета передається
яні ковальській вище професійне училище
номер 24 міста Заставна Яночко виберіть
від мене ініціативу А я зараз якраз
відкрию вашу презентацію і теж поширю
хочу від себе сказати що
насправді дуже класний заклад Я особисто
була в Заставні і бачила Цей заклад
освіти і сподіваюся що
навчання в ньому таке саме цікаве як і
моє
першочергове відвідування так Яночко ви
є чи ви говорите
Доброго дня шановні учасники нинішнього
вебінару Я навчаюсь на другому курсі
вищого професійного училища номер 24
місто Заставна Чернівецької області за
професією перукар-модельєр манікюрниця
уже з перших тижнів навчання було обрано
до складу Президії учнівського
самоврядування і долучилася до
волонтерської діяльності бо згідно
розподілу обов'язків мені було дорожньо
цю справу
ознайомлюючись з традиціями роботи яка
проводилася допомогу ступину навчання я
відкрила для себе дуже багато цікавих
починань які звичайно прагне поширювати
удосконалювати робити більш корисними і
значущими
справжній волонтерство в нашому
навчальному закладі мимоволі розпочалося
ще з початку російського повторення на
сході України і його ефір красу бачить
мудрість чують доброту відчувають
після повномасштабного вторгнення
мозковиті на території України робота
всього колективу навчального закладу
учнівського самоврядування була
злагодженою і постійною Тим більше що
містечко Заставне з 14-го року діє на
волонтерська сотня яку створила яку
очолює на даний час заступник директора
з виховної роботи училище м'якота Марія
Василівна виховання і справи стали
воєнними У своєму виступі хочу
акцентувати увагу на діяльність нашого
учнівського самоврядування яке
спрямоване на волонтерську роботу та
допомогу збройним силам України
досягнення якнайшвидшої перемоги над
російським агресором перші дні війни
стали для нас всіх шокуючими щоб якимось
чином нормалізувати обстановку ми
використовуючи дистанційні та змішані
форми навчання спільну з членами
педагогічного колективу почали шукати
такі форми і методи роботи які б
згуртували колектив вносили кожному
певність на важливістю внеску наближення
Перемоги і здобувачами освіти ми
запросили учасників АТО захисників і
волонтерів військових капеланів Потім
почали організовувати виховні заходи
такі як і спонукатимуть кожного учня до
усвідомлення реального стану справ
пошуку свого шляху в допомозі воїнам
зсув такий легкий
також проводили в училищі та в системі
онлайн загального училищній лінійки
виховні години та годин спілкування
особливо враження здобувачів освіти з
правило проведення заходу ангели тебе
оберігають Коді проведення якого було
відзначено краще волонтерів училище та
показ театралізованої вистави Місячна
соната війни
наступний слайд ще
було оголошено загальну училищну акцію
працівники та учні училища захисникам
України за короткий термін Було зібрано
близько 50 тисяч гривень які з яких 22
тисячі 100 було передано на
придбання автомобіля для ЗСУ а решту
коштів ми використали для приготування
солодощів для наших захисників у березні
місяці
цього року в училищі відбувся
благодійний концерт за участю відомого
співака України Олександра кварти
благодійні внески якого були використані
на для придбання тепловізора для наших
ЗСУ
ще один слайд наступний
наступний ще
волонтери училища побували у Львівському
військовому госпіталі куди возили свої
смаколики та вироби для поранених
захисників
сплетено
сплетену та передано на фронт 4
маскувальні сітки
з перших місяців коли ми об'єднали свої
зусилля змонтовано для обігріву на
замовлення наших захисників всім буржу
яку в даний час маємо
матеріали для виготовлення ще 8 печей
також виготовлено шість кікімор та
сформовано 207 окупних свічок які були
передані на фронт
наступний слайд
ще один
Враховуючи те що у зв'язку із дією
дистанційних форм навчання через
військовий стан та коронавірусні
обмеження дистанційно було на Лавочне
співпраця практично з кожним здобувачем
освіти який міг в домашніх умовах
виготовити для ляльки-мотанки написати
лист намалювати малюнки та зробити
обереги які збиралися і передавалися на
фронт нашим захисникам разом із
зібраними предметами особистої гігієни
теплими речами продуктовими відправками
заставнівської волонтерської сотні
членами якої стали багато працівників
нашого училища
Добре відомо на теренах України
заставнівська волонтерська сотня завдяки
тісній співпраці колективу точнівського
самоврядування фактично створено на базі
училища волонтерство ВПУ №24 місто
Заставна для організації збору коштів
для вирішення на зрілих проблем здобули
чи освіти виготовляли саморобні вироби
випічки якими здійснювали торгівлю
приносили з дому окремі продукти
харчування одягу особистої гігієни
наступний слайд
ще
і ще
спочатку
2022-23 навчального року під
наставництвами вихователів гуртожитку
було пошито 213 прапорів та 164 аптечки
наступний слайд
ще один
і ще
Захисники України щоразу як вдячність
відправляють нам державні прапори і
словами подяки та побажання які ми
використовуємо при проведенні виховних
заходів в нашому училищі наступні слайд
крім цього проводили ремонт військової
форми торборальності Заставни було
організовано збір гостинців здобувачами
освіти для дітей переселенців наступний
слайм
які разом із родинами поселення і
проживають на одному з поверхів
гуртожитку училища у підготовці до
відправих захисникам України які
готувалися зі сталінського волонтерської
сотні наші працівники та учні щоразу
приймають активну участь паралельно Хочу
зазначити що за період війни на передову
воїнам збройних сил здійснюють 74
відправки смачної домашньої їжі та
солодощів ведучи мову про волонтерство і
на ближнє Перемоги не можу не згадати що
з перших днів війни на фронт пішли троє
наших педагогічних працівників це ваш та
вікторів Євгенович Королик Павло
Васильович та Попов Микола Ігорович
серп мобілізованих захисників є Багато
наших випускників які проживають за
межами заставнівщини на превеликий жаль
хочу сказати що серед загиблих героїв та
захисників України також є двоє
випускників училища це колодрівський
Владислав і тарновецький Валентин
свого чи освіти спільної з працівниками
училища щоразу включають полаги героїв
нашого регіону живим коридором
вшановуючи загиблих героїв у форму куток
пам'яті проводиться пошук матеріалів для
створення книги пам'яті та оформлення
постійного діючого стенду у фен
навчального корпусу
зараз до Святої Трійці готується чергова
75 відправка домашних справ вітальних
листів та обереги
наступні слайди
так робота з волонтерства - це постійна
справа але важливо зрозуміти що це
спільна справа важливий внесок кожного у
наближенні нашої Перемоги
віримо що буде Україна також хочу
привітати сьогодні всіх із днем героїв
України який відзначається 23 травня
Дякую всім за увагу
Дякую вам Яну знову ж таки розуміючи
наскільки ваш заклад ще гарний
якщо подивитися на його місце
розташування Я розумію що ви сьогодні
показали душу вашого закладу і власне
низький уклін всім вашим учням
викладачам колегам які долучаються до
такої потужної роботи бо я знаю що
Заставна не таке вже і велике містечко
насправді але коли дивишся кількість
продукції вами виготовлена І дійсно диво
дивуєшся Так у нас наступною буде Аня
Патюк
і Вінницькі вище професійне училище
сфери послуг Анічка поки я шукаю вашу
презентацію я її отримала ви вже Можете
починати Я буду вас супроводжувати добре
Доброго дня всім Я хочу Анна навчаюсь у
Вінницькому вищому професійному училищі
сфери послуг майбутній перукар Я
сьогодні розповім вам про волонтерську
діяльність у Вінницькому вищому
професійному училищі сфери послуг яка
розпочалася ще 2008 року
учнівське самоврядування взяло під опіку
вихованців Вінницького обласного центру
реабілітації дітей та молоді з
функціональними обмеженнями обрій та
Вінницького навчального реабілітаційного
центру гніздечко ми постійно проводимо
там майстер-класи тренінги святкові
заходи тощо вже традиційною стала акція
10 добрих справ спочатку війни в училище
започатковано волонтерський марафон
добрих справ
автослюсарі кухарі кондитери гравці
закрійники та всі педагоги об'єднані
Заради перемоги І продовжують працювати
в рамках марафону ми проводимо такі
акції Дякуємо за захист щедрі вівторок
Повертайтесь живими великодній кошик що
четверга ми печемо хліб та солодощі для
воїнів ЗСУ та поранених що перебувають у
Вінницькому госпіталі провели акцію
подаруй дітям радість зібрали теплі речі
солодощі іграшки засоби гігієни для
дітей з визволеного ізюму плили
маскувальні сітки виготовляли проти
автомобільні їжаки завдяки нашим гравцям
закрійникам та педагогам для військових
пошили 800 футболок 600 трусів 200
балаклак 200 пар носків
что сумок для воїнів наші перукарі
постійно обслуговують
військовослужбовців що перебувають на
лікуванні у військовому госпіталі 25
тисяч гривень зібрали та витратили на
ремонт автомобілів для воїнів ЗСУ 10
тисяч гривень перерахували на громадську
організацію Подільська громада яка
займається волонтерською діяльністю учні
закладу для військовослужбовців готують
вітальні плакати листівки обереги
співпрацюємо з Міжнародним благодійним
фондом ротарі без кордонів шахіна
збираємо одяг продукти харчування
консервацію іграшки книги солодощі Хтось
скаже замало але ми робимо все що можемо
та вміємо ви знаєте деякий час я
працювала в Польщі за кордоном та також
займалися благодійністю
і зрозуміла що волонтерство - це не
тільки збирати кошти це ще розповідати
про нашу Україну про нашу мову культуру
про нашу вишиванку і щоразу нагадувати
про біду яку переживає український народ
Про те що разом ми сила Слава Україні
Слава Нашим героям дякую
Дякую вам Аню от ви мабуть сьогодні
найкраще вклалися в той час який був
Відведений бо ми трошечки затягуємо але
наші колеги які здійснюють забезпечують
трансляцію кажуть що ми в принципі
вкладаємося будемо сподіватися що так і
є і часу в нас є і я зараз хочу передати
слово наші наступні учасниці і рівність
Сенкевич учениця Луцького центру
професійно-технічної освіти поки Іринка
включається Я якраз вишукую зараз вашу
презентацію І те що задоволенням її
запущу
Рина я голова рада лідерів учнівського
самоврядування
освіти Волинської області хочу вас із
знайомити з волонтерським рухом на
Волині та розповісти вам про внесок
наших закладів у майбутню перемогу
ви починаєте Я зараз я вже знайшла вашу
презентацію зараз я її запускаю
[музика]
напрямок волонтерської діяльності це
першочергова допомога збройним силам
України одиноким застарілим громадянам
мешканцям геріатричних будинків
ветеранам педагогічної праці закладів
ПТУ дітям сиротам будинків дитину в
умовах війни особливий напрям допомога
збройним силам України
спробуйте бути хоча б трохи добрішими і
ви побачите що будете назвати зробити
поганий вчинок сказав Конфуцій дні
роботи в закладах ПТУ Волинь ініційовані
лідерами врядування Ось так ми розпочали
наш навчальний рік хочу змінити світ
змінити сам і віддай частині своєї душі
ближніми саме цього принципу
дотримуються волонтери області участь
благодійні акції смілива гривні з метою
збору коштів на допомогу Збройних Силах
України
з
ім'ям
ініціативи голови учнівської
самоврядування Тобто Це була моя
ініціатива відбулась акція у закладах
професійно-технічної освіти Волині за
збору пластмасових кривчиків такі було
перед для утилізації та виготовлення
процесів для наших воїнів
[музика]
волонтерська акція зігрі солдата
протягом року волонтери і колективи
закладів
збиралися зріст папір дістання банку для
виготовлення охопних свічок а також
готували аналітичні набори у цих
енергетичних наборів також входило
написання листівок та виготовляємо сітки
для воїнів з сили
виготовлення Ковельський центр педагога
виготовляв буржуйки для розмінування
заклади харчового спрямування долучились
до виточки на передову
головний принцип гурту це володіти
добрим серцем А вона у нас великі та
добре гурт добрі серця Луцького центру
ПТУ у колі своїх друзів центр
реабілітації усіх інвалідністю джерелом
життя ми долучились до Сонячного сяйва
Сонячної мами був взяли участь у
відкритті фото виставки краса сонячного
очима захисника закладу Андрія Мельника
робимо звіт красивішим а наша держава
міцніше волонтерський гурт добре під час
підготов до мешканців ВПУ до Волинського
обласного центру соціально-психологічної
допомоги акція напередодні Великодні
свята 10 травня 2023 року в Луцькому
центрі ПТУ стартувала акція подаруй свою
турботу яку організували волонтери гурту
досить серця
Напередодні дня матері та міжнародного
дня сім'ї волонтер фігурту добрі серця
Луцького центру ПТУ завітали до цієї
малечі будинку
дитини з подарунками
вшанування пам'яті колеги захисників
закладів
професійно-технічної освіти Волинської
області не огляд представлений показники
і захисниці працівників випускників про
техосвіти моя родина обласний урок
пам'яті і повагу захисників України
Обласний конкурс творчих есе один день
війни один день і противу
дослідно-пошуковий проєкт Небесний
закладено Алея Героїв захисних слів
нововолинського центру ПТО представитель
пцу епіфаній
потреби заснули сьогодні життєво важливі
для нашого суспільства тому продовжуємо
тримати волонтерський фронт та впевнено
блокуємо Разом до перемоги Я впевнений
що ми всі обов'язково складемо усі пазли
свого щасливого майбутнього Я вірю в
Україну і буду посміхатися бо зараз
немає часу плавати тільки прямувати до
перемоги Дякую за увагу
Слава Україні
Героям слава Дякую вам Ірину ви власне
дали такий огляд взагалі від закладів
професійно-технічної освіти Волинської
області я казала в нас сьогодні майже
кожен куточок України присутній не всі
Але половина точно і ми охоплюємо всі
всі географічні частини нашої країни я
не знаю не можу бути впевнена чи
з'явилася в нас Дарія з черкаського
вищого професійного училища бо під час
переклички я вас не бачила і не чула
Даша якщо ви є дайте про себе знати
Дякую
Даша є тому Даша вам слово будь ласка
намагаємося бути в межах 5 хвилин прошу
Доброго дня передаю щирі вітання з
мальовничою квітучою Черкащини Мене
звати Дарья Я голова учнівської
дипломатичної ради державного
навчального закладу черкаського вищого
професійного училища темою мого виступу
сьогодні є волонтерський хар як
навчитися бути на байдужим
А можете будь ласка дати доступ на
демонстрацію може дати доступ ми на
початку зустрічі домовлялись що хто хоче
транслювати скине мені презентацію поки
що вашої презентації не бачила Я зараз
продублюю ще раз свою електронку на мою
перепрошуємо Доброго дня Справа в тому
що в нас були там технічні збої і в нас
частинка Ми з самого початку частинка в
чаті де була ваша презентація в нас
зникла бо ми перейшли там технічні були
колеги надсилаю Ще раз вам свою
електроночку будь ласка кидайте а Дашу
ви можете потрошку розказувати Як вам
живеться бувається в закладі професійної
освіти і чи це просто Чи легко бути
насправді лідером студентським бо я
відкрию маленький секрет я теж колись
свого часу очолювала
Раду своєї академії і можу поділитися
потім в кінці своїми враженнями і
сказати як Це вплинуло вона моє подальше
волонтерства зокрема серед одніх
учнівської молоді різноманітність
напрямів форм та методів волонтерської
діяльності відкриваю широкі перспективи
Для активізації духовного морального
інтелектуального національно-культурного
педіалу що вивчає розвиток молодої
людини і суспільства як сьогодення так і
майбутнього участь у волонтерському русі
дає нам учням училище з однієї сторони
саме реалізуватись А з іншою відчути
себе причетним до участі у державних
справах
сучасних умовах питання волонтерства
виходить на перший план є досить
актуальним зокрема в умовах воєнного
стану бо вимагає переосмислення
пріоритетів переорієнтації поглядів та
цінностей звичайно події що відбувається
волонтерство стало одним із
найпродуктивніших способів допомогти не
лише в контексті соціальної роботи а й в
житті і суспільство загалом Для прикладу
Хочу познайомити з одним із проектів
соціального волонтерства до якого
активно долучилися учнівська
дипломатична рада це створення
волонтерського хабу на базі державного
навчального закладу Черкаське вище
професійне училище Для прикладу
де 24 лютого
2022 року ставте які змінив нас змінив
країну та вніс корективи навіть у
світову спільноту він був
непередбачуваним ніхто не очікував що у
циві державному у світі ми в реаліях
відчуємо значення слова війна тому перші
дні педагогічний колектив закладу
учнівський самоврядування Без вагань
підтримали ініціативу нашого директора
про створення на базі училища
своєрідного гуманітарного центру а в
подальшому означили як волонтерського
хабу який працює активно і на сьогодні
першою і найпотужнішою локацією зважаючи
на те що навчаємо ми у
професійно-технічному закладі який готує
кваліфікованих робітників у харчових та
заранених галузях було приготування
гарячих обідів для наших захисників
щоденно без вихідних бригади кухарів
педагогів залучивши до діяльності і нас
учнів був зранку до ночі готували обіди
кількість порцій зростала похвилинно і
сягала більше 10 польських людей
це було складно але ми можна трималися
бо розуміли що по-іншому ми не можемо
для того щоб хоть трішки полегшити працю
наших кухарів була організована друга
локація заготівельний цех де відбувалася
попередня обробка обробка і приготування
напівфабрикатів з овочів та риби і м'ясо
коли стало зрозуміло що війна не
закінчиться одним днем чи тиждень
з'явилися нові потреби і ми одразу
створили нові локації активно запрацював
гурт волонтерів бджілка до якого входили
не тільки педагоги та учні а й охочі
допомогли місцями
які займалися і до сьогодні зберемо
одягу взуття та допомогою предметами
нашим військовим та внутрішньо
переміщенням осіб
тісній співпраці з комітетом
самоорганізації населення Дніпровський
місто Черкаси яким долучився до нашої
волонтерської діяльності був
організований простір по плетіння
маскувальних сіток та кікімор
у вас пропав звук О все повернулись до
Дякую дуже
з травня і до сьогоднішнього дня
директор нашого закладу ініціатор
проекту знаходиться на захисті рубежів
рідної країни тому ми не можемо зрадити
його ідею Ми допомагаємо нашим
захисникам обмінюємо месенджерами пишемо
листи підтримки допомагаємо Чим можемо
власне продукцію яку викликаємо і
передаємо на фронт або ж у лікувальні
заклади міста де перебувають на
реабілітації військовослужбовці одягу
які придбала йому на кошти виручені під
час благодійних акцій що проводяться в
закладі та я просто відвідуємо наших
воїнів щоб підтримати їх дух читаємо
поезії виконуємо пісні і просто
розмовляємо розуміємо що наші дії тут як
кажуть в пилу наближають перемогу в
Україні
ми вважаємо що сьогодні в умовах війни
волонтерство є тим на байдушнім чим
ресурсом на якому ґрунтується
національно-патріотична моральне
громадянське виховання сучасного
молодого покоління Дякую за увагу всім
мирного неба і творчого успіху
А можете будь ласка відео включити бо
Дякую Дашу Я перевіряю коштині дві
хвилинки свою електроночку поки що не
бачу але ми якщо всі не будуть
заперечувати бо обіцяємо зробити окремо
закладочку новину про нашу сьогоднішню
зустрічі дати лінк на ваші відео
презентації тому що не всі відео були
показані я дійсно Дякую центру
географічному центру України бо в нас
Черкащини власне так і є за теж так
нещодавно відвідували вашу область і
були теж приємно вражені прагненнями
щодо розвитку в нас не так багато часу
власне ми вже перебрали 5 хвилин але в
нас ще є двоє виступаючих тому пропоную
швиденько перейти власне зокрема тому що
в нас сьогодні якийсь такий гендерний
дисбаланс вийшов І в нас більше
виступаючих було дівчат і серед
учасників було більше дівчат а от зараз
хочу надати слово
данилові кучмі президент учнівського
самоврядування люботинського
професійного ліцею залізничного
транспорту Я знаю теж як не просто
довелося
навчатися і мабуть зараз теж вони певним
чином мають незручності цьому закладу бо
одна з або навіть не одна відбувся
обстріл це Харківська область і будівля
закладу була пошкоджена Данило вам слово
а я намагаюся поширити вашу презентацію
Так я почну коли демонстрації і в мене
прохання я буду казати В наступний слайд
ви перегортаєте Добре без проблем але ви
можете вже починати щось говорити Ось
ваша презентація з датою 23.05 зараз я
її просто розгортаю
так так
[музика]
Ага це ще не ваша Зараз ми ось
Добрий день Тема мого виступу
волонтерська діяльність - це частина
нашого життя наступний свет
у відомого філософа Платона є цитата
піклуючись про щастя інших і створюєш
своє власне у люботинському професійному
ліцеї залізничного транспорту одним із
пріоритетних напрямків головної роботи є
волонтерство та благодійність а саме
участь у Всеукраїнських обласних міських
актів та заходах і безумовно організація
колективом ліцею власних заходів і
зазначеного напрямку волонтер нашого
ліцею це здобувачі освіти та їх батьки
майстри виробничого навчання викладачі
адміністрація які вносять свій внесок у
розвиток вологотерства головним девізом
волонтерської діяльності стали слова
даруємо тепло доброти готовність перейти
на допомогу це частина нашого життя
наступний свет
серед робочих освіти ліцею проведений
конкурс малюнків Мамо я бачу війну з
метою допомогти дітям які постраждали
від воєнних дій краще малюнки
завантажували на сайт NFC Project за
допомогою дітям які постраждали від
війни Мама я бачу війну наступний свет
у жовтні 2022 року президент учнівського
самоврядування ліцею Анна гаркавило була
до мене я був обраний в кінці жовтня
вона брала участь у навчальному тренінгу
для молодих лідерів у місті Трускавець
Львівської області
і навчальному який організовувався
українська фундація захист прав дітей на
сьогодні Аня працює волонтером
допомагаючи дорослим здобувач освіти
Вікторія Щербакова волонтерка центру
соціальної психологічної підтримки для
дітей постраждалих від збройного
конфлікту в Україні який працює на базі
ліцею у січні 2023 року взяла участь у
всеукраїнському з тренінгу для молодих
лідерів десь такі команд
прямуємо Разом до перемоги що проходив у
селі Маньківка Черкаської області
організований всеукраїнська фундація
захист прав дітей на тренінгових
заняттях учасників навчали ефективно
навичкам роботи в команді
психологічним аспектом комунікації з
дітьми з інвалідністю як допомогти людям
і не зашкодити собі як уникнути
конфлікту і контролювати ситуацію
наступний свет
Вікторія активно працює для дітей 7-впо
які проживають у нашому гуртожитку ліцею
вона провела майстер-класи з
виготовлення оберегу янголятко весняної
вітальної листівки метелика чупа-чупсика
тощо
учнівський колектив ліцею надав
матеріальну підтримку ЗСУ передали кошти
на придбання 6-4місних туристичних
наметів для бійців 92 окремої
механізованої бригади наступний слайд
також долучилися до всеукраїнської
благодійної акції смілива гривні
організований національним банком
України Ми зібрали монетами
7753 грн 50 копійок на підтримку
української армії та переказали на
спецрахунок НБУ на допомогу армії у
грудні 2022 року отримали грамоту за
активну участь у цій акції дізнавшись
про потребу в маскувальних костюмах для
наших захисників працівники здачі освіти
та й батьки взяли активну участь у зборі
донатів організованим ліцею на зібрані
кошти а саме 27 тисяч гривень ми
придбали маскувальні костюми шапки
рукавиці теплі шкарпетки молотки мастило
для електрогенераторів масу для
змащування пального апарату бензопил та
електропил продукти харчування та ще
деякі необхідні речі і не забули трішки
солодощів усе передали випускникам ліцею
які боронять Україну в складі окремої 92
механізованої бригади імені отамана
Івана Сірка наступний свет
через ракетні удари російської
Федерацією по об'єктах критичної
інфраструктури українці залишилися без
світла і за постійних відключень
електроенергії здобувачі освіти ліцею
разом з керівником гуртка бери і роби
змайстрували альтернативне джерело
Світлані ліхтарики та передали їх у
територіальний центр соціального
обслуговування надання соціальних послуг
люботинської міської ради Харківської
області працівники якого доставили їх
людям уважного віку наступний слой
звуженням поставлено необхідність
окупних свічок для військових коло тих
ліцею долучився до виготовлення
таких сачок зібрали для шанки які
учасники військово-патріотичного гуртка
Нескорені разом з керівником оптиснули
накрутили картоном та передали на
заливку воску наступний свет
чудову команду дівчат-трудівниць вдалося
зібрати здобувався в світі ельвірі тацюн
у своєму селищі Горького духівського
району вони співпрацюють з дівчатами з
різних сіл разом готують захисникам їжу
випікають різні смаколики коли тут
маскування сітки зібране передають
волонтерам які все виставляють на
передову дівчата мають багато світовин
від вдячних військових за їх працюю
здобуваючи освіти третього курсу працює
волонтером Вов Харківська волонтерська
організація під назвою пекельна кухні то
має посвідчення волонтера він разом зі
своєю матір'ю пече хліб я медиків і
військових ще є Денис хасина здобула що
сидіти навчальної групи пмт-20 Переїхав
з міста до івано-франківської області і
волонтери там Він доставляє продукти
харчування засоби гігієни людям які
цього потребують наступний свет
у листопаді 2022 року представники
учнівського самоврядування брали участь
в освітньому мотиваційному проекті
країну взаємно красивих людей
організованим громадською організацією
Google Global у межах компанії вліпи за
себе мета цього проекту активне
залучення молоді до створення образу
України після війни за принципом
Building Back Better наступний слайд
а в січні 2023 року команда учнів ліцею
долучилися до зимового креативного
мистецтва стійкості і створили проект
Нескорені приємно що в такий нелегкий
час Кожен з нас долучився до обов'язки
громадянина України пишаємося що наша
Молодь не стоїть острів А як активним
учасником та надійної підтримкою
наступний свет
Дякую за увагу Миру всім наближаємо
перемогу разом Слава Україні
Героям слава Дякую Данило я тут
зрозуміла що я разом з вами відточую
свої
теж уміння користуватися презентаціями
зокрема користуватися зумом
Дякую друзі в нас лишилося ще одна
доповідачка Христина Кропивницький
професійний ліцей сфери послуг і
торгівлі я вже казала на початку нашої
зустрічі що ми з Христиною нещодавно
бачилися я відвідувала цей ліцей і
Христиночко зараз шукаю вашу презентацію
оберіть слово у вас є надзвичайний
досвід
надзвичайного теж волонтерського проекту
бо
незважаючи на те що ви робите багато
щось спільного і маєте її тож Христинка
а потім ми ще трохи з вами пограємося в
запитаннях відповіді прошу дуже вам
дякую
тож вас вітає Центральна Україна і
сьогодні я рада з вами поділитися
напрацюваннями учнівського та
педагогічного колективу Кропивницького
професійного ліцею сфери послуг і
торгівлі в галузі волонтерства наступний
слайд будь ласка Кожен з нас може
впливати на розвиток України іноді
результат видно одразу іноді через
багато років але долучитися і творити
Країну У якій ти хочеш жити Можна вже
зараз але вміння робити добро не виникає
в людині самопособів потрібно її вчити
доброчинності і милосердів виховувати в
ній потребу допомагати іншим закладені в
людині добро чесність людяність
милосердя відповідальність за свою сім'ю
громаду залишаються з нею на все її
життя люди допомагають людям у важкі
часи Випробування сьогодні милосердя
доброта та допомога відчувається так
гостро як ніколи
виражаючи до вражаючи до глибини душі
показуючи справою що найвища цінність -
Це людське життя
волонтерство - це передусім можливість
впливати на те що відбувається
відбувається довкола ініціювати власні
проекти та змінювати країну далі будь
ласка
волонтерство вже понад 10 років є
важливою складовою
соціально-професійного встановлення
майбутніх кваліфікованих робітників
Кропивницького професійного ліцею сфери
послуг і торгівлі як необхідної умови
формування відповідального соціально
активного громадянина компетентного
фахівця наступний слайд
за 10 років учнівським та педагогічним
колективом ліцею було проведено
майстер-класи благодійні марафони
ярмарки концерти ні добра на підтримку
військових людей похилого віку
онкохворих дітей та людей з особливими
потребами це дозволило нам учнівській
молоді набути дієвого досвіду
доброчинності як найвищого прояву
духовності людини відчути соціальну
значеність професії які Ми забуваємо в
ліцеї навиків до використання свого
соціально-професійного потенціалу в
інтересах оточуючих та громади добре Та
і чуйність співпереживання і щиро
сердечність уміння розділити Чужий біль
вчасно підтримати у важку хвилину
розрадити ці риси завжди були в
характері українського народу
наступний слайд не виключення є і наш
навчальний заклад який дійсно співпрацює
з міжнародними благодійним фондом янголи
життя через проведення майстер-класів
свят та благодійних заходів на підтримку
підопічних фонду онкохворих дітей що
дозволяє розвинути нам організаторські
та лідерські навички
успішна участь учнів у вирішенні бодай
невеличкої соціальної проблеми сприяє
розвитку їхньої позитивної соціальної
активності соціальної творчості далі
будь ласка
забутий досвід особливо був відчутний в
перші дні повномасштабного вторгнення ми
активно долучились до діяльності
громадського простору кроп-кап та
громадської організації серця матерів та
ветеранів Кропивницького через пошиття
пошиття амуніції для військових
забезпечення харчування плетіння сіток
збору коштів та інших ініціатив в яких
проявилися професійні навики нас як
майбутніх кухарів гравців перукарів та
продавців наступний стан
активна співпрацюємо з артмайданчиком
атмосфера мир-2:0 спільно з яким
проводимо майстер-класи плахотвірні
ярмарки концерти на допомогу військовим
та внутрішньо переміщеним особам завдяки
партнерству з громадським організаціями
залучаємо додаткові людські та
матеріальні ресурси для підтримки
закладу та задоволення потреб інтересів
громади поліпшуємо взаєморозуміння
довіру та взаємодію між представниками
різних секторів громади далі будь ласка
спільності його Кропивницький та
громадської організації турбота
впроваджуємо проекти джинса на підтримку
людей похилого віку та клаптики добра
наступний слайд будь ласка на підтримку
дітей внутрішньо переселених осіб які
сприяють розвитку професійних навичок та
формують навички роботи в команді
самореалізації вміння концентруватись а
також сприяють формуванню у нас
учнівської молоді прагнення до
доброчинності і милосердя виховують
потребу допомагати іншим наступний слайд
позитивний вплив на формування іміджу
ліцею мають волонтерські проекти з
наданням безкоштовних соціальних послуг
за профільним закладу зокрема майбутні
перукарі партнерстві з майстрами надають
безкоштовні перукарські послуги для ВПУ
та вразливих категорій населення що
стало основою зародження ідеї про
великий проект волонтер+ як у втілює на
Кіровоградщині громадська організація
слов'янський культурний центр
Задзеркалля у партнерстві з дитячим
фондом
за програмою розвиток та підтримка
молоді Кіровоградської області В умовах
воєнного стану через молодіжні
ініціативи обшивки наступний сайт
через роботу ательє кроп-стиль та
перукарні краса створений простір
задовольняє потреба вразливих категорій
населення зокрема внутрішньо переміщених
осіб послугах ремонту та пошиття одягу
перукарських послугах завдяки
волонтерській діяльності майбутніх
Кравців закрійників перукарів та молоді
зі здібностями до такої діяльності що
дозволяє з одного боку вразливим
категоріям громади зокрема внутрішньо
переміщеним особам одержати якісні
послуги
Перепрошую одержати якісні послуги в
яких є нагальна потреба з іншого боку
учнівська молодь Волонтери які набувають
досвіду доброчинності та розвивають
важливі компетентності для
самореалізації в різних сферах
життєдіяльності наступний слайд
підсумовуючи вищий викладене наш досвід
довів доцільність залучення до співпраці
різнопланових організацій
майбутній кваліфікований робітник який в
процесі професійного встановлення разом
з набуттям досвіду волонтерської
діяльності набуває соціальних навичок як
запоруки успішної професійної кар'єри у
переможній Україні а ознайомитись із
нашою діяльністю Ви також можете в
соціальних мережах Facebook та Instagram
і на сайті нашого закладу Дякую за увагу
Слава Україні
Героям слава Дякую Христина ми звісно
трошки перебрали з часом Але я думаю що
всім було цікаво і корисно почути а
нашим стікерам було надзвичайно цікаво і
корисно виступити тому ще раз величезна
подяка я сподіваюся це ще наша не
остання зустріч Можливо ми знайдемо інші
теми цікаві для вас і там де ви можете
поділитися власне своїми враженнями Я
знаю що ми працюємо дуже довго але все ж
таки хочу запропонувати вам
не те щоб погратися але власне трошки